he is now in a PhD program
but his peers in the program are closer
in age to his children than they are to
him
and they call him dad
brutal
please welcome Dusty
yes I am in the Army however anything
and everything I'm talking about today
has nothing to do with the Army uh you
can see that the conversation is going
to be about fantasy football I think any
colleague that I've ever had passed or
presence knows that whatever
organization I work for I'm a part of
always has a fantasy football league
going on and that becomes the most
important thing uh that we do in that
agency as my friend Robert reminded me
earlier so I'm excited to talk about
this very grateful for the opportunity
from Jared to do it uh hopefully even if
you're not a fantasy football or
football fan uh you can get something
Irish out of what we talk about
um so as I mentioned we're going to talk
about
um you know three major things the ESPN
API to get our data integer programming
which is how we're going to model and
also our
um but before we do it a short uh side
note I've taken up this hobby of anytime
I go somewhere I go for a run and I
usually try to make it in the shape of
an R so this is my DCR it wasn't
actually today uh it was when I lived
here recently as you can tell it's a
hobby uh I ran
I ran in an italics are at West Point
um this one looks like my daughter drew
it and this one was in uh it's off the
screen which makes me kind of sad that
was in New York City uh hopefully it's
not the case for everything that I have
just briefly a little bit about my
background
um I'm a former engineer officer with
tourist Iraq and Afghanistan spent some
time now as an Orsa operations research
systems analyst at uh West Point as a
faculty member and previously at CAA I'm
currently in a PhD program at Baylor
um here's some action shots of me like
typing on a computer because that's what
it seems like I do most of the time
um hanging up a tank here uh an Iraqi
tank which I probably should have been
doing and here I am trying to pull a
Humvee which wasn't wasn't very
successful at
um I've got a lot of math-ish
educational background probably too much
mostly operations research I went to the
Ohio state which is pretty cool
um go Buckeyes and currently Baylor
my family who mean the world to me I
show my wife Jill I refuse to put the m
in Michigan as most Buckeyes do but
that's where she's from uh and I've got
you know a new fan family of bears that
we're really excited about it but what I
assume about you today is you may or may
not know much about football but that's
okay if you don't you don't need to know
know much uh I'm assuming almost no
knowledge of fantasy football so I'm
going to give a little bit of background
on how this works so the math makes
sense and then uh maybe a little bit
about integer programming but it's okay
if you don't have much uh knowledge
about that either and lastly I assume
quite a bit of knowledge of our stats
I'm going to show some code but even if
you don't know exactly what I'm doing
hopefully we can we can hang on
um so let's talk about fantasy football
uh in summary for those that aren't
familiar fantasy football like most
fantasy sports uh you join a league of
people usually that you know and you uh
kind of Select players that play in the
National Football League and based off
their performance you gain points for
their performance and every week you
play head to head with another player
and if you score more points then you're
or your your players score more points
than who you're playing against uh you
win for that week
um as you can see here
um we encourage in the Baylor stats
Department League that I'm in to pick
some pretty uh you know mathie names I'm
the armchair quarterback uh I beat tidy
vs Terry tibbles oh and I should also
note before I go too far you can see my
record there so I don't really know if
you should trust me about winning
Fantasy Football I'm two and nine so uh
I probably shouldn't even have mentioned
that
would you participate in this league
rosters have a certain makeup
um as I show here you have one
quarterback two running backs two wide
receivers a tight end another player a
defensive player and a kicker
um
and you can see here the second win I
had the year that I decided to show
against the strong law of large
victories which is a fun Pawn off of the
strong I'm not even gonna gonna go there
because I'm not doing so well in theory
right now uh in class
um now to kick off the league you have
to select players one of the traditional
ways of selecting players is a snake
draft and that's where you all take
turns in the league picking someone but
a more fun way to do it I think is an
auction draft what happens is someone
nominates a player and then everyone has
200 of fake money and whoever's willing
to spend most you know the most money on
that player gets them but of course you
know the obvious cost if you spend a lot
of money on a good player you have less
money uh on on other players and there
are you continue uh bidding on players
until your entire roster Spilled Out for
for every League now there are a couple
strategies as Drew Brees here is
thinking about one of them is you can
just spin big on a couple players and
that's a technique and it sometimes
works well you can spend 60 six dollars
a piece and you have a dollar left for
the rest of your team but you have three
good players the other option is to try
to get Bargains throughout the draft but
that's risky as well maybe there's a
more intelligence solution
um which is where I want to introduce
integer program
um with integer programming
what you
what we're going to do to try to
maximize the expected Point production
of our future team is we're going to
make a few assumptions one we're going
to assume that the players in the league
that we know how many points that
they're going to make there's all sorts
of experts out there that are making
these projections so we're going to
assume they're correct second we're
going to assume that we know the cost
that we can get the the player at uh in
in the auction so with those two
assumptions that we know aren't true but
we're gonna we're gonna proceed with it
with those two assumptions the goal is
to maximize the expected points and we
have a number of constraints that we
have to adhere to one is we have uh you
know only two hundred dollars right and
we also have to build out our roster
uh according to you know the certain
positions otherwise I just get a bunch
of quarterbacks because they score more
points than anyone else
um another important information uh that
I once I mentioned before we proceed is
I'm going to assume that we don't care
about our bench meaning that we can just
get whoever's left at the end for zero
dollars which is fine and secondly I'm
going to assume that we're indifferent
to our defense and our kicker and
usually that's a pretty good assumption
because their performance throughout the
season is largely arbitrary so don't
wait don't waste money on
um
okay getting a little mathy
the goal that we have here I'm going to
try to move my mouse around to point is
in the upper left hand part what we're
trying to maximize is the points of
player P your qrwt which is their
position person player indicator and the
x is a zero one indicator meaning
they're either on my team or not and
this is subject to you know if they're a
quarterback running back wide receiver
tight end
um now if we just didn't have any
constraints we would just take every
player and we would you know run up a
lot of points but as Lee Corso says
every Saturday not so fast my friend we
have some constraints that we have to
adhere to and among those are the uh
positional constraints like how many are
on our team we get one quarterback so
across all the quarterbacks which I
can't even Point well I wish I had a
really long pole across all the
quarterbacks we can only have one
it is possible to have up to three
running backs if one of them is this
extra position this Flex that we have
down here which is equal to six because
those are
um
you know the running back wide receiver
tight ends you can have up to six but no
more than three running backs no more
than two tight ends and uh we also have
the last Financial constraint which is
that every player on our team has to sum
to 200 or less and given those
constraints uh we can proceed forward
but one of the things that I think is
more interesting about this is how we
actually get the data right because we
could just spend a lot of time and
create a list of how much we think it's
everyone's going to be but the really
fun part is is that ESPN has an API and
there's a niche community on Reddit
who's done a lot of work to try to like
hack into this API they don't publish
any information about it hopefully they
don't turn it off but uh
I found out about the API originally if
anyone's got any experience with this by
spying on the browser and chrome like
you can watch all the apis that it hits
up when you load a page so I found this
API
um which has this uh this base of a URL
and you can see it hitting up the
fantasy football data which is known as
Kona player info for some reason
um and I've hosted all this code online
I'll give you the link to that later
um
but the problem I had is when you run
this code AS is you only get 50 players
and there's way more than 50 players
that you're interested in which is where
I had to rely on the Reddit Community I
appreciate those folks
there's this block of code that sends a
header in the request saying hey send me
more than 50 players and I requested a
500 here
um afterwards it comes in like a not
very readable format you have to turn it
into a Json that's how you say it uh
hopefully I'm saying it right uh and
then we have to like pick that file
apart to get the data I know there's
more eloquent ways to do this
um but the way I did it was I just
started reaching down into this nested
data frame this nested file selecting
out fantasy points what season it is the
scoring period ID which doesn't make
much sense right now but when you see
the data in a second you will and then
do a little bit of cleaning to get the
exact row of that player you want get
the right season
um still filter for the maximum fantasy
points for the season because it also
gives weekly expectations uh there's a
lot going on here so I built a function
to do one of them and I decided to pluck
out one player in particular I know one
of Jared's favorite players is step on
Diggs uh but he's one of the higher a
predicted fantasy football players that
exist and I think you have Jared maybe
the credit for him being on the Vikings
for a little while uh but here's an
example of one output but we create a
function to get one output we can now
map that one using per over all the
fantasy football players and we end up
with a uh well we also need to clean
that one up a little bit too it takes a
lot of cleaning because you got to
identify their positions and all sorts
of things but once you
download and clean all that data now you
have the expected fantasy points for
each player and I show the top 10 from
each position hopefully these names look
familiar and they should look like
they're pretty good I'll also note now
that every time I run this code and
render the presentation it goes out and
hits the ESPN API and pulls the most
recent season predictions so the reason
these are all predicted to do well is
because they've already been doing well
at the beginning of the Season it had a
few other players on here that were that
were ranked quite a bit differently
um
but uh I think that's that's kind of a
feature and not a bug now let's get down
to business of actually modeling NR
there's a number of integer programming
or linear linear programming functions
um in us at CAA have used a number of
these to do some modeling maybe I'll
talk about that at the end but the one
I'm most familiar with and I wish I knew
some of these others better is LP solve
um some of these other ones you can use
more of like notational syntax but this
one you have to build out your matrices
and all the and all the fun things
so let's talk about how to do a model
with help you solve
um first you got to give it your
objective equation so this
fobj the objective function fantasy
objective equation that I've got there
is a whole bunch of ones and zeros
um of
uh oh no it's a whole bunch of points
like how many points does each player
have the second one is the constraint
Matrix so what are their positions
um like it's a bunch of zeros and ones
like are you a quarterback are you a
running back so on and so forth
um and the last row is the expected
point value which I kind of overlooked
but ESPN also projects how much you
should spend on that player uh if you
want them on your team I I completely
blew past that earlier I should note
that now
um and then
we build the like is equal to
directional uh Vector which you can see
here
um see here
here
and then I can scroll a little bit and
you put you know is equal to one is
equal to less than or equal to three uh
and then that
then I I wanted to show show you as well
like what these look like even though
this is like enough to make your eyes
bleed uh with like code and Vector
numbers that's just terrible but uh to
actually get the solution
um you run the lp function and the lp
function you tell it the direction which
we want to maximize points
um you know what's our objection
objective function what is our Matrix
you you can see each one of the
arguments that you provide and then
lastly you designate that it's all
binary because you can't have like a
fractional Tom Brady which as much as I
think he's great he's probably a
fractional Tom Brady as is
um I hope he doesn't hear that you say
that I think she thinks great
um
okay
and this is what our solution looks like
a bunch of ones and zeros you should
notice there's an up ones to fill a
fantasy football team so here's your
answer go win your league right
um You can't do much with this so let's
take it back and clean up the results a
little bit find who actually these ones
and zeros belong to and put them on our
team now if you're a football fan or a
fantasy football fan or anything I hope
that you feel that this would be a
pretty darn good team if you were able
to get all these people in your league
right like this would probably win uh
every week but as I mentioned before
every time I run the code it re-updates
uh everything
but the
thing I want to mention is
when you go into your fantasy draft and
here was the mistake I made the first
year I did this I went in I had you know
my list of players but all of a sudden I
want to spend 18 on on Josh Allen but
somebody's willing to go like 50 bucks
on them I'm like no my the math says 18
and that's it like I'm not spending any
more than eighteen dollars and then that
completely messes up like everything if
I spend more than it I don't have the
same like best team so
um there's certainly uh a challenge to
overcome and that's what I want to talk
about for a second here is what happens
if things don't go as planned
um
well
let's see if I can do this live
I don't have this hosted and I need my
mouse back oh no there it is
all right got some code here
this is dangerous y'all
dashboard
run document they're going to work
nice
well not nice hold on
I don't know why but sometimes I have to
go here and change it
like this
and it works the next time I don't know
why
and if it doesn't work like this I
change it back and it works next time
there we go look at that
so
here's the team that I should get right
it should look familiar we saw it a
second ago
um I want Josh Allen dog on it but I'm
unwilling to go over more than 18 so I
built this application to go in
and I really wish I was mirrored right
now somebody else got Josh Allen
my o key doesn't work
there he is Josh Allen
and now it removes them from the data
and reruns my integer program and tells
me who the new best most
points likely to score points fantasy
football team is uh and you can keep
iterating through this if you lose
players and then as you say I do get
I don't know
who's my running back up there is that
uh
Josh Jacobs
I like all the Josh's I guess
well
are we gonna work there we go then he
comes off the board and I also provide a
little bit of functionality that if I
had to
well
this is going well
there we go if I had to go over I can
like make adjustments like if I win a
dollar or two over I can adjust this and
all of a sudden you see it changing my
my team because I don't have as much
money as before
um
I still lost this year so
I uh uh if nothing else it helps you
make a more informed decision when you
go into it I think that's what we find a
lot in our jobs is that we have all the
analysis
um a lot of times it's not the right
answer but if you didn't even have
something to like go down that road
you'd just be completely lost so I'd
rather operate with something like this
in my back pocket than than uh than
anything else and
my final
final thoughts here
um
what I would love is if somebody out
here was like super passionate as well
about this and had time I've got this
repo hosted with with everything please
Fork it update it make it better
um
maybe we can all win our fantasy leagues
together like our our powers combine
super Jared and is like our costume
um Jared wore his costume so I had to
wear mine as well uh so I appreciate it
thanks everyone for the time uh look
forward to chatting with you afterwards
thank you